get started everyone uh welcome to the
algorithm session
um i let's get started with the first
talk so i'm going to hand the floor to
michael wren who's going to talk about
circular trace reconstruction go ahead
michael
thanks yeah so um this was joint work
with sham nirayanan
so i'm just going to be giving an
overview of our
results the problem we're working on in
like future directions
for the problem
so um first i want to
briefly talk about trace reconstruction
in
for linear strings which is the
variant that people have worked on
before so the setup is that
we have some unknown binary string x of
some given length n
it's going to be passed through a
deletion channel in which every bit
is going to be independently deleted
with some fixed probability q
and then the resulting bits that remain
are going to be concatenated into
a shorter string called the trace so the
question is can we
construct figure out what the original
string was from looking at a lot of
traces
and how many traces do we need to do
this to be able to do it with high
probability
so uh as an example
uh let's say we have
uh this string here um and you can think
of the
uh queue as around like a half so like
half of this will be deleted
and then so it's gonna be passed to the
channel and the red bits will be deleted
so oh um
okay so the red bits will be deleted and
then
so the remaining bits are concatenated
and the string we see after
um it's passed to the channel is one one
zero one one zero
so we wanna see like if we get a lot of
these traces can we figure out what the
original string was
so the motivation for studying this
comes originally from
some problems in computational biology
about dna
so we can think of like the strings as
a sequence of dna so like there's a
multiple sequence alignment problem
where we want to figure out
what the dna sequence of an ancestor
looks like if we can sequence
the descendants uh there's also dna
storage where
we can store data in dna and we can
recover it through sequencing
but reading the data is kind of noisy
and uh for example
um bits can be uh randomly deleted when
we read it
so some previous results in trace
reconstruction for linear strings so
there's a few different variants that
people work on
so in the worst case we want to be able
to reconstruct any arbitrary string x of
length n with high probability
so in this case whole instant at all
showed that
this can be done in e to the root n up
to log factors and the exponent
traces this is improved simultaneously
by nazareth perez
and day o'donnell cervedia to e to the
cube root of n
and very recently chase improved this to
e to the
fifth root of n up to log factors
uh another variant um is average case
reconstruction where
the string x is um chosen randomly from
all length n strings so this is
different and easier because for example
if there's some
string that is very hard for us to
figure out in the worst case in the
average case it's very unlikely to occur
so holding stand at all showed that if
the deletion probability is low enough
then we can do it in polynomially many
traces this was improved to
e to the root log n for deletion
probabilities less than a half by perez
and jai
which was then improved by holden
pimento and perez to e to the cube root
of log n for any constant deletion
probability
there's also the question of lower
bounds so like how can uh
can we prove any lower bounds for those
two questions
and uh holden and leon showed a lower
bound of n to the 5 4 up to log factors
for
worst case and roughly log n to the nine
fourths for average case which was
improved by chase
into the three halves and log into the
five halves
so um the variant we introduced circular
trace reconstruction
is very similar except now the strings
are going to be cyclic strings or
circular strings
it's still going to be passed through a
deletion channel um every bit is going
to be deleted with
independently probability q the bits are
going to be concatenated into a shorter
circular string
and we want to reconstruct what the
original string is up to cyclic rotation
so equivalently we can think of this as
a linear string except it's going to
undergo a random cyclic rotation before
it goes through the deletion channel
so the motivation for studying this is
that uh certain types of dna
are circular so if we want to think
about those applications
before for those types of dna we should
think about circular trace
reconstruction
so here's an example we have a length 12
circular string
it's going to be passed through the
deletion channel the red bits are going
to be deleted
uh the remaining bits are going to be
concatenated together into a shorter
circular string and we can read it as a
linear string by picking an arbitrary
bit in the circle to start with so the
question is
can we get similar bounds on the sample
complexity
for the circular case compared to the
linear case
so we have results in the three areas i
talked about before so first
for worst case reconstruction um we have
some arbitrary
we want to reconstruct arbitrary
circular strings x it's going to be of
length n going through a deletion
channel probability q
so um our result is that if n is the
product of at most
two primes then um we can recover x with
um e to the uh cube root of n traces up
to log factors in the exponent
uh so the reason that uh there's this
dependence on the prime factorization of
n
is that in our proof which um so we
modify
the approach for linear strings um where
we
want to consider a certain polynomial
that
that has coefficients depending on the
string
except to deal with the circular strings
um we need to incorporate like we need
to encode the circular nature of the
string somehow so we use
anthros of unity and if n has too many
prime factors
then the nth roots of unity aren't as
well behaved and our approach doesn't
work so in fact we've shown that the
only end for which our approach works um
are exactly the end which are the
product
of at most two primes
for average case reconstruction uh so in
this case the circular string is some
random
circular string um we've shown that uh
we can
reconstruct it with polynomially many
traces
where the exponent is going to depend on
the uh what the
the deletion probability and it'll tend
to infinity as the deletion probability
tends to one
finally for uh the lower bound we have
um
we've shown that up to log factors we
need at least n cubed independent traces
for the worst case
compared to the end to the three halves
for that is known for
the linear strings
so um there's a lot of future directions
that
this can be taken in so first um so
this work was completed before chase um
released his result about um e to the
fifth root of n so the question is can
we match this
even for say n prime and
um regarding that um there's a question
that we
if we can remove the dependency on the
prime factorization of n in our
upper bound um
and also whether um we can sort of match
linear strings and get a subpolynomial
for the average case
uh so the difficulty here is that um
most of the previous work for the
average case
where a subpolynomial bound was obtained
um
sort of tries to reconstruct the string
from beginning to end so
the difficulty for circular strings is
that there is no beginning to the string
and uh it seems difficult to align the
string so that we can consider a
beginning
um there's also the question of if we
can improve the lower bound for the
worst case
um maybe to a super polynomial bound
since
it seems easier to get we can get like
better bounds for this compared to the
linear string case finally
can we get better bounds if the deletion
probability tends to zero as n goes to
infinity so like non-constant deletion
and i think there's actually a talk
later in the session regarding
this uh okay that's it thanks for
listening to the talk
thank you much applause um
we're going to save questions for the
end of the session um if you have
questions for the authors
please you know write them down to
remember them because it will be you
know half an hour from now
uh let's go ahead and switch over to
nathan
who i think are you the presenter for
sampling arborescences
in parallel
is audio and everything working yeah
working great if you want to do your
screen share
all right so let me give the floor over
to nathan who will talk about sampling
arbor essences in parallel
okay so hi everyone i'm nathan i'm a
sophomore at stanford and here's some
joint work with nema ahmed and aaron on
sampling our presences in parallel okay
so our story
sort of begins by asking like the most
basic questions we can in cs when it
comes to giving a graph and some
structure on the graph
so you know the sort of level zero
question one might ask is you know
so let's say we're caring about spanning
trees right the easiest question we can
ask is does this graph contain a
spanning tree and can we find it
and then two of the sort of slightly
harder but still really important
questions we can ask are
can we count how many spanning trees
there are and can we randomly sample one
and it turns out for a large class of
problems and structures these two
questions of sampling and counting are
equivalent up to a polynomial time
reduction
but the story gets a little bit more
messy when we look to restrict the
computation
beyond just sequential algorithms so
specifically we're looking at this sort
of world of parallel algorithms where
we're in a pram model with these
processors interacting via some shared
random access memory
and now just as polynomial time was the
scold standard for sequential algorithms
we can define something known as nc or
nyx class where the total work is still
polynomial but it's heavily paralyzable
up to being left with just this polylog
runtime
and now the story and this equivalence
gets a lot more messy
so returning back to this idea of sort
of sampling and counting
there are all these structures for whom
counting can be done by
taking some determinants of matrices and
in general all this linear algebra is
very very paralyzable
thus for all these structures we have
exact counting in parallel but
for all these structures sampling is
pretty much open for efficient parallel
sampling algorithms
and so this is like a very vast
disparity in contrast to the equivalence
and sequential algorithms
and our work is sort of tackling this
gap from one specific object and
what we're looking at is arborescences
which are this generalization of
spanning trees to directed graphs
so now you see that the edges still form
a spanning tree and they're oriented
such that aside from a root vertex
every vertex has one incoming edge and
these are once a structure for whom
exact counting can be doable by
taking a few determinants and we show
that there's an efficient parallel
algorithm
to sample our resonances from weighted
directed graphs and we sample our
residences according to this probability
distribution
proportional to the edge weights
and we have a couple basic building
blocks we use in our algorithm
so the first is this theorem by albus
embroider which tells us that
this task of sampling can be reduced to
simulating a random walk
and recording the first visit edges so
recording every edge that visits an
unvisited vertex
and by doing this um and just extracting
all sorts of visit edges we are left
with an arbor essence that's distributed
how we want
and you know this has been used for a
very fast sequential sampling algorithms
for spanning trees but it's slightly
less obvious why this helps us
since um random walks are also this very
inherently sequential process
but here comes in our second building
block which is work by tang
and what he showed is that we can
actually very efficiently simulate these
random walks in parallel
so we can generate this polynomially
long transcript in
nc and so the key intuition or idea
behind tang's idea
teng's work is that we can do this
classic divide and conquer strategy of
simulating the first half of our random
walk
and the second half of our random walk
in parallel before aggregating
everything together
and while we can't really stimulate the
second half of our random walk without
knowing the starting vertex
we can sort of be brute force about this
and leverage polynomial processors to
simulate every possible
second half of our random walk before
aggregating everything together
and so putting together tanks sort of
parallel random walk techniques with
aldous sprouter already solves this
sampling problem when
our graph has a cover time which is
polynomial because then we can generate
this polynomially long transcript and
with very high probability we'll have
all first versus edges which we can
extract
but um very few graphs actually have
these guarantees of polynomial cover
time
um this is only guaranteed for
unweighted graphs and they're examples
of weighted graphs and directed graphs
for whom we have exponentially large
cover times
so we need a third sort of key building
block which is short cutting
to remove this obstacle and the sort of
main idea behind
shortcutting is that for alice broder's
theorem
when we simulate a random walk we only
care about the edges which visit
unvisited vertices
so that means a large part of a random
walk is not important to simulate and we
can
ignore it so concretely imagine we're
doing some random walk that's currently
bouncing between vertices d and e
um after vertices d and e have both been
hit
we really don't care about our random
walk until we finally exit this cluster
and thus we just wanted to sort of fast
forward a random walk until saying when
we finally leave do we leave through
edge db or edc
and it turns out that in general given
some vertex set on a graph
and a current location um the all these
out
if we wanted to ask the question of when
our random walk finally leaves this
cluster of vertices what edge do we take
those probabilities can be computed very
efficiently in parallel
and this means that we can essentially
sort of very efficiently fast forward or
walk
if we know what sort of clusters we wish
to ignore
and so combining all these techniques
together i'm going to go into a
high level overview of our algorithm
and so we begin by doing some
pre-processing our graph on our graph
and this is going to um ensure sort of
like all that fine print on all the
spreader slide is fulfilled
and also ensure that our graph is
finally eulerian and soilarium property
and the fact that eulerian graphs can be
decomposed into cycles
will be really important to allow us to
sort of divide our graph into these
clusters where
intuitively each cluster is tightly
connected by edges such that
a random walk spends a lot of time so
bouncing around within each cluster
before leaving
so these clusters are kind of the ideal
target for us to leverage the
shortcutting inside from a few slides
ago
and then we sort of keep on recursively
dividing these clusters into
smaller and smaller subsets of vertices
such that each cluster can be divided
into
smaller clusters that also sort of waste
a lot of time on our random walk until
we're left with just leaves as vertices
and then if you realize that um because
from our shortcutting slide
given any cluster in a current location
we can very quickly simulate the
directly seeing like these outgoing
edges
what this means is that we can generate
these transcripts of
um sort of jumping edges where now
instead of being the canonical
random walk that looks like a sequence
of edge vertex edge vertex
we have intermediate states of vertices
so for example
so these transcripts sort of correspond
to random walks simulated up to the
resolution of some subset of vertices
so with this concrete interpretation of
we're bouncing around in some cluster
before
exiting our cluster through some edge
and then bouncing around a new cluster
before exiting through a subsequent edge
and we can simulate these random walks
on every single cluster
so for the smaller clusters we can do
this while conditioning on both an
outgoing edge
and a starting vertex so then the key
insight to note is that
while we do all the simulation in
parallel these intermediate states which
again represent this
kind of unsimulated random walk on a
cluster with a conditioned outgoing
vertex
are exactly what we were already
simulating in parallel at during this
time step
and what this allows us to do is sort of
stitch all these transcripts together
until we're left with this final
transcript of
i guess a mixture of vertices and edges
such that for each cluster we have sort
of polynomially many
edges which jump between those children
this final transcript sort of
corresponds to
a random walk which with a lot of parts
already omitted and done quickly
and um for some polynomial um
we can generate this transcript very
quickly and efficiently in parallel
so then lastly we can extract all the
sort of first visit edges
from such a transcript and you know with
very
very hopefully you know this will in
fact give us an arbor essence
so aside from our algorithm the last um
i guess ingredient needed in our results
is
analysis of random walks on directed
graphs which
allow us to which kind of coupled with
how we
performed our decomposition and finding
found these clusters
tell us that for some polynomial length
each of these
this transcript that has a mixture of
jumping edges along each cluster will
in fact contain all sort of first visit
edges with high probability and thus
will very likely be able to walk away
with our randomly sampled our varesence
and be happy
and so as a recap um we've done all this
work to
produce a very efficient parallel
sampling algorithm for arborescenses
and this is sort of a first step in
bridging this big divide between
parallel sampling and parallel counting
algorithms
and this big divide naturally leads to a
lot of open questions when it comes to
structures and asking do these
structures have efficient algorithms for
sampling in parallel
and so two of these structures which are
very closely related to our residences
are eulerian tours and regular metroids
and then more generally we can look to
achieve quick parallel something
algorithms through something known as
wilson's algorithm which is
this random walk-based cousin of aldous
embroider which also has generalizations
to high-dimensional matrix
and most generally that big list of
combinatorial objects
all have sort of very efficient counting
algorithms but have
open parallel sampling problems so with
that um thank you all
and i guess we'll push questions to the
end
thank you nathan let's get some silent
applause
uh if we could
go ahead and switch over i think to
chinholi
is that right who will be giving the
next talk awesome
um so
yeah we have we have your audio and we
have your slides so
uh the floor is yours chinho to talk
about polynomial time trace
reconstruction in the low deletion rate
regime
okay hello everyone so this is a joint
workload
an idea there rockers a video and
scientific
so in case you missed the first talk let
me tell you what is a trace
reconstruction problem
so in this problem there is a deletion
channel that acts on a string x
so it does is that you first delete each
piece of x independently
with some probability data and then it
will output
the concatenation of the surviving piece
so let me give you some examples here
so for example this is our x and then
if we pass it to the direction channel
then imagine it maybe the second bit or
the fifth bit of x
and then it outputs the concatenation of
this surviving bits which is in this
case
one one one zero one and then maybe the
next time it deletes the
first bit and the second last bit and
then the concatenation of this surviving
base will be
zero one one one one so finally
maybe this time it only is the third bit
so this time you get a
so this time you get a longer output
string
so note that as you can see here the
outputs in outputs you don't know the
deleted positions
and also the length of the output are
not
always the same okay
so we call these independent samples
coming from the deletion channel
the traces
so what's the trace reconstruction
problem so the problem is that you are
given some
um unknown so you are different from
traces of an unknown
mp string x so you only get to see the
right hand side here and then the goal
is to reconstruct x exactly with high
probability
over the decision channel so
one one question is uh to study is how
many traces
are sufficient to recover x and then
if so what if there is an efficient
algorithm charge with this task
so just to give you some motivation this
problem has some applications in
computational biology where the traces
correspond to
some usage sequence and then so you're
given some user dna sequences and then
you want to
reconstruct the original dna sequence
from this music form
now let me quickly talk about some
previous results
so this problem was introduced by batu
canon canna and mcgregor
in 2004 so in that paper the given
efficient algorithm for dilution rate is
less than one over square root of n
and in subsequently we have these uh
recent work that
for example say or downloads a video and
nazarov and paris independency show that
for any constant deletion rays there is
an algorithm that uses
exponential to enter 1 3 samples in time
and this was very recently improved
to so this exponent was improved to one
fifth by chase recently
so in terms of lower bound this original
work by uh
bkkm they showed that for any dilution
rate delta you need
roughly delta n samples and then
in another work by chase built on that
builds on the work of protein and i and
they
show that for any constant deletion rate
you need some polynomial number of
samples
so you can see that all these recent
work have been focusing on improving the
sampling complexity and the runtime for
constant deletion rate
so they are essentially they are less
practical than
the bkkm algorithm which runs in
polynomial time
so here in this work we ask the
following question suppose
we insist on the error from being
efficient then what is the largest
deletion rate that we can handle
so here is our result we showed that for
any constant epsilon
and dilution raised delta that's less
than one over n to the one-third plus
epsilon
there is an efficient algorithm that we
covers x with high probability
okay so this work improves the exponent
of one half in this work by bkm to one
third
in terms of the addition rates that you
can handle so maybe
you may think that this improvement may
not be um
too much but then notes that when the
division rate is
say one over uh square root of n then
actually the previous best upper bound
uses exponential angular 1 6
traces and we believe our approach could
actually work for
larger division race delta say one over
poly and delusional
so let me talk about our algorithm so
our approach is similar to the one given
by bkkm which is also a
alignment based approach so before i
tell you the algorithms i have to
introduce a notion called gestures
so as dashers is just a long
repeated pattern of constant size so how
long is
roughly one of a delta b is known
so for example if this is our unknown
string
x then if you have at least one or delta
many
uh consecutive ones then this is a one
desert
uh here you have a zero one desert
because you have many
zero one zero one zero zero c one and it
has
a ease of length at least one over delta
so here is our algorithm so our
algorithm automates between two
procedures
one is called a bitwise majority
alignment shocking shot is called bma
so it will reconstruct x up through a
few bits
of the desert and then the next
procedure will be to find the end of
this desert
and then align this point to some new
traces
so let me uh give you an example
so for example this is our unknown x in
grey
and then at the beginning we draw some
traces
okay and then we run our bma algorithm
on these traces
this algorithm will give us a candidate
uh x hat
so x hat may not completely agree with x
but we know what it guarantees is that
it's correct
with hyper ability up to the first end
beast of the desert of the first decade
so we know that these prefix of eggs are
correct
and we know that there is a desert at
the end of
the reconstructed prefix so now the goal
would be to find the end
point of this desert so we run our next
procedure front end
so what it does is that it will locate
this endpoint
in x so now you know this is the
endpoint and you know the pattern so you
can fill out
the rest of the piece here
okay and then you will also draw some
new traces
and then you align this endpoint of the
desert
to these new traces so you know that
these arrows are pointing to
where this uh end point is in the x
so now you align the traces so you can
re just
again alternate you switch to bma and
continue running this algorithm
so we will we construct the rest of the
x again
now this may not completely agree with
x because it may contain a desert but
you know that is correct up to
the first mbs of the next desert so you
switch to finance find the end of the
desert
and then fill out this pattern
draw some new traces and then align
these endpoints to these new traces and
then you continue
running this algorithm using the same
principles
so here you run bma again and not
because there's no more deserts in x
so you know that um the algorithm
just terminates and then you know that
this x hat is going to be
correct with high probability so i won't
really have time to tell you the details
of the analysis
so let me just summarize so here is our
summary we show that for any constant
epsilon and
addition raised delta that is at most
one over n to the one thirds perception
there's an efficient network from that
recovers x or with high probability
using polynomial number of samples and
running time
and our algorithm alternate alternates
between two procedures
one is bma and the other is front end
so a one bottleneck is that our analysis
for finance
requires this uh square root of n delta
to be less than one over delta
now if you work out this inequality you
will notice
delta is at most one over n to the one
third
and then this is the reason uh why our
algorithm only works for one over n to
the one third plus epsilon
so one natural open question is whether
you can use this kind of approach to
give an
efficient algorithm for deletion where
it's say 1 over n to the 3
0.32 or more generally whether it works
for
say one over n to the epsilon for any
constant epsilon
so this is all i wanted to say about
this work uh thank you for watching
thank you chinho so i'll give live
applause everyone else can get silent
applause
uh if we can go ahead and switch over
to the next speaker who i think is mike
sinckowski i'm not sure if i'm
pronouncing your last name right
uh yeah synkowski but awesome so if you
could go ahead and screen share and i'll
remind all the participants that i hope
you're
writing down and saving your questions
we will have panel
slash question time at the end here and
also i'll remind you that you can
communicate with the authors via slack
if you like each of these papers has its
own
slack channel uh
so let's give the floor over to mike who
will tell us about a new connection
between node and edge depth robust
graphs go ahead mike
hi so i'm mike koski i'm going to talk
about
a new connection between node and edge
different let's graphs
and this is joint work with jeremiah
blocky
so a depth robust graph is a directed
acyclic graph that has
certain properties which we'll define on
the next slide
um and the main reason we're interested
in depth of bust graphs is they have
multiple applications to cryptography
for example depth of scraps are used to
create secure
data independent memory hard functions
which are used in password hashing
um additionally they have applications
to blockchain so for creating proofs of
space
and proof sequential work um so these
are the motivating applications for
studying depth of buzz graphs
um so now i'll kind of go into the
formal definitions
um and first i'll um introduce a the
negated definition because it's a bit
easier to illustrate
um so we say that a um a dag g is ed
node reducible if there's some set of
vertices of size of most
e such that when you remove that set
from a graph
the depth of the graph is at most e and
here
depth is defined to be the number of
edges in the longest path
and then we say that g is ed no depth or
bust
if it's not ed node reducible um so here
we have this example
tag on five vertices if we just remove
one node
we see that the remaining graph has
depth at most two
um so we call it one two node reducible
and similarly if we can
we remove any node and we see that the
depth is always
greater than d or greater than one so we
call it one one node depth robust um and
similarly
we can find edge steps or bus graphs
where we remove edges
instead of nodes so here again we have
the same graph
if we just remove one edge we reduce the
depth to be at most three um so we call
it one three edge reducible
and this graph will be a one two
introducible cause to remove any one
edge the depth is always greater than
two
um so the reason we're interested in
sort of comparing node and edge to
epibus graphs is they're
basically all the applications i talked
about earlier require node of the bus
graphs
um so memory hard functions proof of
space but
we think that edge depth of bus graphs
are potentially easier to construct
so if you think about removing an edge
from a graph doesn't affect the graph as
much as removing a node
and then removing all the edges incident
to it
so we have these two kind of example
constructions that are well known in the
literature
so the grades construction is an edge of
the bus graph
that has a very simple construction
analysis
but this graph the egs graph it's a no
difficult graph
that's very complicated construction
analysis
so what we'd like are new techniques for
constructing node depth of the bus
graphs
um and i should note that most of our
known constructions of depth of bus
graphs are
some sort of variant on the egs graph um
so you'd like some sort of new way
of constructing no depth or bus graphs
and so our main result is that um
we come up with a transformation so we
transform an ed
edge depth of the bus graph that has m
edges into an e over two
the node bus graph that will have
constant integrity
and order m and vertices
so if we apply our transformation
directly to the
we apply our transformation directly
directly to greats we get a no different
bus graph that has these certain
parameters um the exact
ones aren't necessarily important but
the what you should take away is that
this is improvement on prior
constructions
for intermediate eye values additionally
this makes progress towards resolving an
open problem about the pebbling
complexity of
data independent memory hard functions
and so
to create this transformation um we
introduce and define
graphs that we call st robust graphs
that'll be sort of our
key technical ingredient in the
transformation
and these ester bus graphs have uh
additional applications to proof of
space
and what we call source distinct depth
of those graphs
so the high level of our transformation
is we take a highly educated graph
and then replace each node of the graph
with an ester bus graph
and then the resulting graph then will
have constant and degree and be highly
node of the robust
um so a question i'll spend the rest of
the talk answering is what property
should this stress graph have
um another question you could ask is can
we actually construct these graphs and
the answer is yes but it's in our paper
um so the key building block we have is
what we call maximalist tier bus graphs
so we have some dag here
on the left um that has n inputs and
outputs
and so for all k less than or equal to n
we can remove any k nodes from this
graph and then there'll be some sub
graph
of this that has at least n minus k
inputs and
minus k outputs such that each input
connects to every single output
so for each input on the left there's
some path they can reach
all these minus k outputs
and one of the main results from our
paper is we construct a family of linear
sized
constant and degree maximal square bus
graphs
and so here's an example for n equals
three if we remove any one node from
this graph
there's some subgraph that has two
inputs and two outputs
and each input connects to every output
similarly
if we remove any two nodes from this
graph then there's a some subgraph that
has one input and one output
and they're connected
um so to kind of return to what our
transformation is so we have some
directed ace to click graph and then we
will
um basically swap in for each node
as a steer bus graph and um
the size of the graph will depend on the
maximum in and out degree
and we sort of just randomly assign each
input
to an input of the s t bus graph and
same for the outputs
and so to kind of talk about why we want
this s-tier bus property
and we'll kind of just zoom in on one
node here say it has three incoming
edges and two outgoing edges
um so if we just remove one node from
this graph
then by the s t r business property um
there'll be some sub graph that has
two of the inputs and two of the outputs
and each one of the inputs
um can connect each to all the outputs
um and so what this corresponds to is
um sort of like saying we remove
the two edges that are no longer covered
by the st robustness property
so um if we have our transform graph
and we remove um e over two vertices
then that corresponds to um some set of
e
edges and that those that set of edges
is what we um say remove
the original graph and since it's edge
depth robust we will get a
path of length d and because of the uh
connective property that each
input can connect each output in the
anterior plus graphs we can
map a path from the original graph back
into our transform graph
um and just to summarize um so we have
this new transformation
from edge structure bus graphs to no
depth of bus graphs that improves
um our constructions for certain
parameters
um to do that we define and construct it
as tier bus graphs
um and i didn't have time to talk about
them in this talk but
they have s two bus graphs have sort of
independent applications to proof of
space
and uh source to sync the bus graphs
and uh that's it
thank you mike um we have one
last talk so if we could go ahead and
switch over i think to joshua wow
um who must be winning some kind of time
zone award because i think he's coming
to us all the way from sydney uh so
joshua the floor was yours to talk about
algorithms and hardness for
multi-dimensional
range updates and queries go ahead
awesome
uh thanks sam so uh i'm joshua al i'll
be talking about
our rooms and hardness for
multi-dimensional range updates and
queries uh this is a joint work with
angus for tosser
so oops okay so let's say
you have an array a two-dimensional
array that's initially
uh all zero so it's an array of integers
it's all zeros
uh we're going to design some sort of
data structure
that can perform range updates and range
queries to this
array so some examples of this
let's say we want to add some constant
to
some range of cells in the array so we
might add six to these cells we might
add two to these cells forming this new
array
and we also want to support range
queries so for instance we might select
a range
in in this case all our ranges are
orthogonal ranges we select a range and
we ask for a sum so in this case the sum
of this range is
66. we're also interested in
different sorts of updates so for
instance more complex updates might
provide a constant
along with the range and we replace each
of the elements in that range with the
maximum of that constant and the the
cell's existing value
so as you can see here before we had
uh two cells that were that had value
two
they've now increased to seven but our
two cells that had value eight
uh their value has stayed the same and
after
performing such updates we will ask
we'll also support range queries which
uh ask for the sum of values in a
particular range so in this case this is
54.
so we can define a class of problems or
we do define a new class of problems
formed by choosing some dimension in
this case
two dimensions choosing a set of updates
that we support
in this case plus updates we call them
and max updates
uh as well as a query so in this case
our query operation is sum
and different sorts of problems can be
formed in this way and we're interested
in the complexity of different sorts of
these problems
for simplicity and for the purpose of
this talk i will just focus on this
particular
variant so plus updates max updates and
some queries
[Music]
so when we consider problems of this
kind we're going to measure complexity
in terms of
the number n of operations so we start
with a
an arbitrarily large grid or an
arbitrarily large
array initially all zeros and we just
measure complexity in terms of the
number of operations that are performed
and it's known that in one dimension we
can perform
for this particular problem all updates
and queries
in order and log squared and time so in
operations either an update or a query
what's been mostly unexplored prior to
this work is
well how hard is this in two dimensions
how hard is this in in higher dimensions
things like that so to answer this
question
and to also consider why we're actually
interested in problems of this kind
i'll give a reduction from threesome so
i'll show how the
data structure i introduced at the start
of the talk can be used to solve
threesome efficiently if an efficient
algorithm for this data structure exists
so the three-sum problem which you might
be familiar with gives us input
m integers and it asks well are there
three values a b
and c within this set of integers such
that
the sum of a and b is equal to c
and the three sum conjecture posits that
this can't be done in truly subquadratic
time
that is for m integers there's no order
m to the two minus epsilon time
solution for any positive epsilon
okay so let's see how such reduction
works
let's say our array a is just formed
from the values one two
three and four and five we
start with our grid that's initially all
zeros as before
and from this array we can form an
addition table using our plus updates
only
so we can add one two three four and
five
to each of our columns and we can add
one two
three four and five to each of our rows
now at this stage each cell of the array
contains the sum of exactly two elements
in
a i will ignore double counting for now
we'll just we'll that's dealt with uh in
our paper but
for now let's just ignore double
counting so each cell
will contain a possible value of a plus
b
so what we're going to do is we're going
to iterate through a
and try each value of a as a possible
value of c
and see if that appears in the array so
for instance let's say c
is 4 we want to check if there is
some 4 that appears somewhere in the
grid
and that's equivalent well that's
equivalent roughly to asking
how many 4s are in the grid and we can
write this as
counting the number of elements that are
at most 4 in the grid
and subtracting off the number of
elements that are at most 3 in the grid
because we're dealing with integers so
let's just focus on counting the number
of elements that are at most 4 in the
grid
to do that we can use our max update so
from the grid that we had earlier that
addition table
we can maximize the entire grid
with four now the values that have
changed
are those that were previously at most
four and that they're now going to be
exactly equal to four
we can do the same again uh maximizing
the whole grid with five
so what's changed now is that every
value that was precisely
4 in the left grid has changed to 5 in
the right grid
another way of thinking about this is
that the only elements that have changed
from the left grid to the right grid are
precisely those
that were at most four in the original
grid
so the sum of the right grid has
increased
exactly by the number of elements that
were at most four
in our original grid so we can write the
number of elements
at most fall as below
okay so that means that once we have our
addition table set up
in a constant number of updates and
queries that is operations
we can check if a particular element
exists within the grid
repeating this for all our m elements
gives us a reduction that
uses order m operations and this implies
that there's no truly subquadratic time
algorithm
for this data structures problem when we
measure complexity in terms of the
number of operations
n now this is just one problem we
consider in our work
we consider actually a sea of other
different variations of of our problem
by considering different sets of updates
and queries
so over in the top right we have this
plus update
max update sum query uh variant that we
considered
and we showed that under the three sum
conjecture uh there's no truly
subquadratic time algorithm for this
but undefined under other fine-grained
conjectures
we can also show various other lower
bounds so
for instance under the orthogonal
vectors conjecture we can show that
both of these are hard not just in two
dimensions but also in
uh in d dimensions and we know by just
tessellating
uh one dimensional one-dimensional
instances
we can actually solve in the same time
relative reasonably naively
the same problem for a whole range of
different updates supported
simultaneously
so this forms and a nearly tight
complexity class up the top
then down below from prior work we know
that in roughly linear time
when the number of dimensions is
constant we can support
just these plus updates and sum queries
as well as max
updates and max queries so this forms a
another complexity
class down the bottom what gets
interesting is somewhere in the middle
so in the middle we have some single
update single query variants
for which we've shown conditional lower
bounds
conditioned on the online matrix vector
conjecture and the opaque shortest path
conjecture
for different problems and we establish
matching
into the one and a half upper bounds for
this
for these particular problems so we also
have some problems
that we for which we've uh found truly
some quadratic
upper bounds uh but we don't know if
there's a lower bound better than n to
the 1.5
so interestingly uh for these two set
update plus
some query problems for these two
problems we find
we give a reduction to um to range
inversion counting
which can be solved with matrix
multiplication
and so we obtain truly some quadratic
lower bounds there
and finally there are some variants for
which we don't know more than this
so we have maybe some rough connections
with some of the problems that we've
already studied
and it's not known to us whether or not
there are a better
upper bounds or better lower bounds so
we don't know which precise to which
complexity class
uh it falls in so we hope that this
class of data structures can inspire
some future work
perhaps you being used as a primitive
and more complex algorithms
or just for showing the the hardness of
other problems
uh thank you
thanks joshua was from from here
um great so we have about 12 minutes
left
in the session um
and since we have a pretty disparate set
of topics
uh i'm not going to
try too hard to get questions that uh
apply to all of the papers at once
um i would like to open the floor to
questions to particular authors
uh now and if if you guys folks want to
think about a little bit i also have
some questions to ask
but i will give a moment here
to see if any hands go up if there are
questions folks would like to ask about
any of these talks
so i have i have a question for
the authors of the trace reconstruction
papers
um that came earlier in this session i
wonder if
um any of the authors would take a stab
at comparing the techniques in the
papers what are their
strengths and weaknesses we didn't we
were short talks we didn't get to hear
much about the techniques but whether we
could hear about
just uh how the papers compare on uh on
an ideas level
michael do you want to go first
uh sure so um i guess one thing is that
um
so our paper didn't really address
efficiency at all so
we only looked at really the sample
complexity and we didn't think too much
about
whether our process for reconstructing
the string can be done
efficiently so
[Music]
whereas chin hose paper
um is more about that question
um otherwise i think so for us um
like i said before uh because
we're looking at circular strings um
there is no like
notion of beginning so like the
techniques
like that they use um it seems pretty
hard to
get them to apply to the circular case
because when we need to find the
beginning first
so is there you know is there you only
have you're going to draw polynomially
many samples
um and i guess you're saying there's no
there's not any hope
of figuring out which sample came from
which which traces come from which
rotations
like if you knew that then then you
would be back in linear trace
reconstruction right
yeah but this is somehow too hard
um awesome
so i guess in terms of the deletion rate
when in
when the deletion rate is constant and
all these recent papers the two they use
is kind of different from the ones for
low deletion rates so the low division
rate is one uh
this alignment base where you draw some
traces and then you align them to
some points in eight but then uh this
con
concentration rate uh the technique is
more like
um this polynomial method you are where
you prove some extremal bonds of
some polynomial with bounded
coefficients
so it's not there's no really the notion
of alignment in this
technique got it awesome
this is only for worst case and i'm not
thinking for every case there is
they use some alignment technique
combined with this worst case approach
uh there's a question in the chat from
cam musco so who asks for circular trace
reconstruction with like 1 over root n
deletion probability
what's known versus the constant error
regime so if you do low error
in the circular setting
uh so as far as i know there is nothing
known about this yet so this is not
something that
we put a lot of time into thinking about
um but one would assume that you can get
much better results than like
e to the root of n
um i have i have actually one more
question about this on trace
reconstruction before we
bring some other folks in um this is
more open-ended
do you do either of you think that there
are
um models that would be interesting
in between average case and and worst
case
yeah so so in the upcoming soda like in
a few days i will talk about this uh
smooth analysis of trace reconstruction
okay so there's like an interpolation
between the worst case and
average case oh very cool yeah
and then we give a efficient algorithm
for any constant
perception of the worst key string
in the constant deletion rate regime
yeah for any constant division
so there's there's been some discussion
in the chat about um
depth robust graphs but i actually
wonder if we could bring some of it out
here so i think one thing that's being
talked about are some
questions about lower bounds maybe oh
actually that's
something i wanted to know about from
the talk so could you give a sense of
sort of what quantitatively the upper
and lower bounds are
on on depth robustness and what you
would hope for for various applications
yeah so there's a um kind of a known
upper bound um
for on edge depth robustness um
[Music]
kind of we looked at uh it's like i mean
i i don't know if it
matters about discussing exact
parameters but uh
what should we think of them as being
linear in number of nodes or
polynomial or like very rough things
it's like if you can remember you can
remove um
if you if you can remove um the number
of edges times
i or so sorry um you can have
the depth of the graph by removing
the number of nodes so m divided by log
n
uh edges so there's a kind of a general
like known a way to reduce the depth of
the grass
graph um half by removing
m over log n edges and so that's kind of
the upper bound um
and so we'd like to construct graphs
that
um their depth robustness it matches
that bound
so i kind of talked about the um
coupling complexity uh relating to the
pedaling complexity of
data independent memory hard functions
um and what's been shown there
is the um
headline complexity is greater than or
equal to e times d
so um if you take a
depth of bus graph and then you say
label it using a hash function
um where like the label of each node is
like say you concatenate the labels of
the
parents and then hash it um that would
give you a
highly um secure uh
memory hard function from a diplomas
graph
and so our construction gets closer to
the bound
than previous known constructions for
certain values of the parameter where i
isn't
close to one or log n but it doesn't
actually quite achieve it
so that's what i was kind of talking
about there
awesome thanks the floor is open if
others have questions for any authors
let me ask a question of joshua
can you give a sense of how you
um arrived at the sort of
zoo of different updates and
and query types and whether they're kind
of rules of thumb for what makes
a combination of update and query easy
easy or hard like are there common
structures between the easy ones and the
hard ones
sure so i don't know if there's any
particular rule of thumb
to answer the first part of the question
how we sort of arrived at
at this zoo or this set of updates and
queries we restricted our updates to
um just a particular set of objects like
plus updates max
updates and setup dates which sort of
just replace the value
of cells in some range uh these sort of
come from
the whole problem idea is sort of driven
from olympiad style problems where
um these are focused a lot in one
dimension in sort of computing olympiads
and not much is known in higher
dimensions so those sorts of operations
commonly appear in those settings and
that's
why we sort of targeted on this
generalization
for rules of thumb or intuition as to
why some are hard and some are easy
i think we've established that setup
dates seem fairly doable
in almost every case even along with
other updates
in truly some quadratic time but
max updates intuitively seem to be a
little bit harder
the patterns they produce you can
produce um sort of
quadratically many different um sub
regions which
gives rise to a bit of like hidden
complexity but we don't have anything
hard on that
other than when you can combine that
with a couple of other updates you can
immediately get
reductions from say threesome or from
orthogonal vectors which which mean
they're
quite hard to as compared to the other
conjectures
thanks
let me let me uh maybe we can conclude
the session with a
question um oh i think something
appeared in the chat
awesome a question from um cam musco
again so one question i had about the
sampling structures in parallel talk to
any of these gaps relate to computing
eigenvalues in parallel
or parallelization of other linear
algebra primitives so i think this is
for nathan
okay let's see um
i think um i've been like all this work
has kind of been done with like a lot of
basic access to their algebra operations
already being doable and parallel and i
think
the general gaps between sampling
accounting are more just a product of
the reductions being very inherently
sequential than any sort of
i guess limiting case of like what we
can do in parallel from linear algebra
primitives
but i also don't really know so this is
like a no with a big asterisk
[Music]
i was also curious whether um
are there any indications that there
could be problems
which uh accounting versus sampling
problems
which uh are equivalent in the non
you know in the in the sequential
setting but actually
do have different complexities in the
parallel setting
or do you think that everything should
be that it really should be equivalent
they should be equivalent in the
parallel setting as well
i think they're a lot harder to do in
parallel but like being hard to do in
proving that they're not doable or like
[Music]
so certainly
i think uh a sentiment of
hands in the air with lots of exciting
things to explore is a great way to end
the
the session so um we'll wrap up there's
a virtual coffee break right now let me
remind all of you who are still here
that there are long versions of all of
these talks on youtube i watch them all
they're great
um and there are slack channels for all
of these papers if you want to discuss
further with any of the authors
so thank you all for attending and i'll
see you in the coffee break
bye